what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts um where I
battle
my coffee addiction every day
and fail really
so today I'm going to talk about a
couple things
um how I got to London why I hate London
why I'm moving to Chicago what other
cities we may move to in the future and
how to work for me if you want to be a
part of the jpt network so and and why
I'm starting this network okay
so
how I got to London so about three years
ago now
I was working this dead-end job I was
selling copiers and guys I hated my life
I hated selling copiers it was like the
worst thing you could possibly sell
and I told a story on Tick Tock okay it
was like about my family or whatever
and
when I told this story it went stupid
viral like four or five million views
and I got like 15 20 000 Tick Tock
followers and
that was when I decided I was going to
go into media
because I realized I was good at it
and I realized that
there is so much media out there that's
just like negative right and it's
promoting things like degeneracy it's
promoting like negative things basically
and I felt like I could be a force for
good and media because people tend to
think I'm funny or interesting
um and I don't know I just I felt like
called to it that's that's the only
thing I could say to describe it I don't
know how I can like describe how I got
here other than I feel like my whole
life has been leading me to this point
and I feel like I am called to do this
um
so what I did was in that moment I
decided I was going to quit my job
selling copiers
beard and I was gonna become a tick
tocker YouTuber whatever
um
so um about one or two months later I
quit my job and I literally just showed
up at my parents house and I said yep I
quit my job I'm gonna be a tick tocker
and my dad thought I was nuts
um but the crazy thing about my dad
is that he would always support me no
matter how crazy it sounded
so um I quit my job I moved home and I
was supposed to go play in England for a
year
um and get my masters and I didn't
really care about my masters but I was
gonna play Pro in England get my masters
and I wanted to make enough money online
to basically play pro while I I made
content right
so my dad
um I moved home my mom's like what are
you doing here
um
what did I do next
oh covid canceled my season so then I'm
living at home and I have nothing to do
other than make content I'm jobless
it's covered and I'm living in my
parents house so I stay there for a year
and I start building this Tick Tock
YouTube thing
um and I'm basically just unemployed
living at home at my parents house so a
lot of Clips have come out saying like I
was mooching off of my parents or
whatever I don't do that anymore
but back then you know I was living at
home so you know but my dad again so
supportive even though he didn't know
anything about social media whatever
um
I go to England and I'm playing pro
or when I'm playing Semi-Pro volleyball
I'm trying to get a pro contract and I
decide to start this show
and what I liked about London was it was
so diverse and I never lived somewhere
with like that many diverse opinions
like I met a girl from Spain there's a
girl from Germany on my team and I
thought it would be so cool to make
um
a show where we all talk about
relationships which is something we all
have in common
and what happened was there was a lot of
Concepts from like red pills I'd been
reacting to Red Pill content that my
friends didn't know so I would basically
make these series and these shows like
red pilling my friends and it just got
bigger and bigger and everything just
you know exploded as you guys know
so that's how I ended up in London and I
ended up staying in London a second year
I was offered a pro contract I turned it
down because the YouTube thing was taken
off
um but
I decided to stay because I just started
hiring people like it was just getting
too big too fast and I didn't have time
to move so what I did was it you know I
made this office in London and then I
started signing talents
um so I signed King Richie's I signed
Auntie Jenny and I helped them build
their channels and they both got like 40
000 Subs in like a couple of months
right
management got kind of difficult um so
the last couple of months have been a
little bit crazy
but
um I've just hated London to be honest
guys I and nothing I I am in the wrong
part of London like my producer says I
might like it more if I was in the west
I'm in the East I've heard the East just
isn't as nice
um
but I just haven't been happy here I
feel like
people get to me more than they should
because I'm not at home I feel like
there's just something about being a
different country like away from all of
your friends and family like you're just
not as grounded
um so I came home and I've been looking
at cities and the cities I've been
looking at are Chicago because I'm from
here
um
Miami Nashville and even Vegas a bit
but I decided as you guys saw yesterday
if you didn't see my office tour video
the first place I'm gonna move to is
Chicago
first office I'm gonna build
and um the reason I picked Chicago is
honestly guys it's just easier like my
parents live here I can stay at my
parents house
um God willing you know I said dad I
promise I'll do the dishes more I'm
sorry I'm sorry about last time
but my dad's like the nicest guy so
um so
moving home to Chicago at least to start
like I may go to a different city I also
want to coach my sister in basketball
um
I've just I don't know
so Andy my dad gave me his old office
building so essentially his office
building is like worthless because of
association fees or something that's
what he told me so he said I could just
have it look if I'm getting free office
I'm coming I'm a big I like free stuff
you know what I mean but essentially
I really wanted to help fight like woke
culture like I just think there's so
much media that is negatively
influencing kids and teenagers and young
adults and if we could make media that
is like cool and entertaining that
people want to watch because I'm sorry
the left is just so much better at
making entertaining content like
conservatives are just boring sorry guys
um I just felt like it could help you
know I mean I I think the culture war is
a losing battle but
I I think that it helps
um
so my plans for the future
is I want to have content houses in
major cities probably all the cities
that I mentioned but to start London
Chicago and I want to sign talents to
host shows in each in each branch
basically I want I want to roughly have
five in each
um I think I found a girl that we're
gonna sign soon I'm pretty sure
um we already have two in London so
ideally we're gonna find two more maybe
three that tops probably
then in the fall so a lot of you guys
have asked to work for me we're probably
not going to hire anyone in Chicago
until the fall so it's starting in
London in London we need
um
we need we need an uh an added we're
either gonna get a part-time producer
and a full-time editor or someone that
can do both
uh maybe some interns that can do
thumbnails this summer
yeah that's all in London East London
um
Chicago
and we're looking for two talents so
what is the best way to get hired okay
I just pearly things
contrary to popular belief we do have
very good work environment you know
not gonna name names
um
the best way to get signed and hired is
honestly you know it's funny I think of
the people that I hired
most of them just showed up that don't
show up unannounced but most of them
just offered to work for free for a week
and then they were good and they were
helpful and they got the job I'm not
saying to do that but
that's how my intern like my interns was
like oh can I intern for free I was like
yeah I like free go ahead
then she was so good at the recruiting
stuff I hired her
um my other producer got on the show
and said he would start working
immediately
boom hired
um because I'm just getting all these
messages about asking to work for me
and a lot of guys are wanting to like
come from out of state and I'm just like
or like fly or whatever but I'm like
look I'm not coordinating
you just gotta show up
say you could start word I'm not even
saying to do this I'm just saying this
is what's worked
um oh God it's kind of hot in here I
don't want to turn on the car because
the air is just so loud
um sorry
but yeah that's um that's what we're
doing right now
um
plans for the future
yeah so ideally we're gonna do these in
a lot of different cities but to start
it's London Chicago the next place I'll
probably go is Miami I kind of just
follow where my parents houses are so I
like being by my parents you know
um
yeah
and I've gotten a lot of criticism
saying that you know I'm too modern for
wanting to do this or whatever but you
know the way I look at it is if it gets
to be too much I'll just I'll stop doing
it
got a lot of criticism for this
you know and really long term I'm not
looking to be in management like
I I have men do that you know I'm just
looking to talk for a living but in
terms of the types of talents I honestly
want a talent that's like
the types of talents I'm looking for I'd
like an older guy that has had a career
in something he could talk about so a
lawyer would be interesting a therapist
that's like more red pill
um I just that would be interesting
ideally London right now so someone
that's in London
um we're having guys go in and like
pitch their ideas whatever
[Music]
can I open this window hold on hold on
um yeah window open better okay
ideally someone that could
we really don't usually sign people that
already have followings but we're not
we're not you know we're not opposed
completely
but yeah
what I look for because people are
asking me what do you look for and
people you hire
um hard-working for talents creativity
is Big so someone that like like one of
the girls that I think we're gonna sign
like she pitched a whole
idea of like she gave ideas for videos
that I wouldn't have even thought of
because it's harder when we have to like
hold your hand and say you do this do
this do this which we will do for some
people but you know that's like a plus
um
someone that's hard working because
really if
if you're a talent like you have all the
resources you could stream 12 hours a
day if you wanted to and when I was
coming up I probably would have
um
yeah that's I mean mostly just
hard-working creative
um why I'm moving to Chicago but yeah
I'm trying to think if there's any other
questions people had
but yeah I think this will be a cool
Network
um I have a network name we're switching
the name it's not going to be jpt
Network I'm really excited I'm not going
to tell you guys yet
um you gotta wait for that
but yeah let me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell talk to you
next time